we've always been people who think we
shouldn't do
any vaccines at all anti-vaxxers some
call them these uh vaccine dissidents
we have a lot of them here and well
globally there is
a lot of people like that experts
believe but when we have
massive vaccination sweeping vaccination
then it might be
all good soon and there's no need to do
vaccines some people think after that
because there's no disease there's no
virus but as soon as the
overall vaccination level goes down
reaches some certain threshold
here you have it an outbreak and people
are running stomping on each other
to get their shot but it's too late so
we should
listen carefully not to those people who
do not understand about these things who
believe rumors we should listen to
professionals it happens all over the
world
some say there is no such virus there is
no pandemic
people do say some people adults
well-educated people
they say it out loud i don't know where
did they get that
it happens all over the world yes it's
just something all the leaders of the
world agreed upon
can you imagine that
you